uh Leah Rachel von essen writes to the
humanities festival I'm inspired by
sanz's character she wrote books only in
parentheses so okay I'm inspired by
Songz's character in the way her soft
skills aren't denigrated even as Arya's
the more classic strength warrior do you
think they parallel each other how does
their relationship mirror the dynamics
of real-life sibling relationships well
I hope that they're both realistic
characters in some sense I've known
people who were like both of them and in
some sense I'm like both of them I've
been asking and we're talking about two
of my women characters girls in that
case and I've been asked about writing
girls and women in my books I have the
advantage I think of in A Song of Ice
and Fire
is that I have a lot of women and
therefore I can do a lot of different
women characters I in an interview that
I did in in Canada a number of years ago
the the host asked me how do I write
women characters and I said well I have
this revolution idea I I act as if women
were people and
[Music]
that's my feeling now if you if you have
a book and you only have one woman
character and sometimes does not room
for anymore because you're writing a
short story or a novel that that only
has a three or four main characters
people sometimes take it oh that's his
opinion of women or something because
this character has these flaws but you
have an advantage when you have 20 women
characters that you can show the variety
of people you know that did some of them
are noble and some of them are selfish
and some of them are are smart and some
of them are stupid and I think that's
true of all groups you know men women
straight people gay people whatever
color that they come in all varieties
and even the individuals have couldn't
evil within them I always try to do
because I think it's realistic and I
think we're all great we'll all have
good and bad in us we've all done good
things and we've all done bad things and
we we can do I mean real history is full
of stories about people who did
something wonderful on Tuesday and
something horrible on Thursday same
person there's a wonderful writer who
passed away a few years ago I'm not a
science fiction writer but Pat Conroy
have any of you ever read Pat Conroy
terrific terrific writer one of the
great writers I think of the 20th
century he wrote a lot of his books were
made into movies to Great Santini
the waters wide which was made into a
movie con RAC based on his own
experiences teaching the words of
discipline but probably the best-known
books of his is is the Prince of tides
and I remember that book that book has a
character in it who is a absolutely
abusive father he terrorizes his
children he abuses them both verbally
and physically he's a
horrible to his wife he is a really
despicable horrible person but there are
flashbacks within that to world war two
about an American aviator flying a
mission over Nazi Germany who is shot
down and he parachutes out to safety but
now he's in the middle of Nazi Germany
has to get back to the lines and he
makes his way through through the German
lines you know hiding hiding in
haystacks and you know occasionally
meeting Germans who try to turn him in
and in other Germans who are kind to him
and hide him and you know it's an
interesting secondary storyline it's the
same character and you realize that you
read this you're reading this story
about this brave American aviator trying
to make his way through two Nazis and
get back to the lines and you're really
rooting for him and you identify him and
you think he's great and then you get to
the present day and and he's this
horrible wretched person based on
Connery his own father who uh who was
mistreating his family and I love that I
mean the depth of character there was
amazing and that the fact that Conroy
did it so adroitly so that's that's some
of my views on characters and Arya and
Sansa indeed many of my characters are
complicated people and I try to show all
of the complexities I don't want them to
be just one note Arya is certainly more
popular than than salsa but Sansa has
her people who love her too and of
course we'll have to see when I write
the book the ends that I have in mind
for both of them Wow
yes I mean it takes me back to the point
you made earlier about length right and
one benefit is that we can actually see
that character transformation even over
the course of a single novel as we can
see this character begin in one
condition and somewhere
so I'm gonna give our final question to
someone named Adam Presta Jacomo who
wants to know what is something are you
here alright did I say your last name
sort of right great nailed it okay
our good friend Adam wants to know what
is something that makes you happy
[Music]
there are a lot of there are a lot of
things that that make me happy you know
I I love books reading a good book makes
me happy especially you know I read I've
been reading since I was a small kid I
still read voraciously I read a chapter
or two from a book almost every night
every once in a while I pick up a book
where I read that chapter 2 and then I
have to read another chapter in another
chapter in another chapter I wound up
staying all night I love it when that
happens I love good movies I love good
television shows that kinds of get my
hooks into me and I have to binge them
all on Netflix I kind of hate the
concept the binging but I find myself
doing it anyway as my waistline will
testify I love good food especially you
know I mean Greek food in Chicago Opa
Opa great barbecue when I'm in Texas in
New Mexico where I lived I moved to New
Mexico in 1979 and I can never leave
because I became addicted to green chile
which you can really only get in New
Mexico as someone there knows the truth
of what I speak and you'll probably all
boo me for this but of course pizza in
New York
[Music]
[Laughter]
it is what it is so I love all that and
I love writing my own stories and
particularly I love finishing them
I actually don't love I mean people say
do I enjoy writing I don't like writing
writing his heart writing good I'm
constantly questioning myself every
sentence I put down I wonder whether
it's good enough or or you know I reread
what I wrote yesterday and I hate it
but when I actually finish a book you
know the rush that comes through me it
was easier to read short stories then
because then I would get that rush you
know every few weeks but now I get that
brush every you know eight years or
something like that but it's a great
rush and I'm hoping to have it again in
the relatively near future when when I
finish winds of winter but you know I do
know that today after I announced that a
day after when's the winter comes out
I'll get the first text saying when it's
dream of spring coming out
so you know these pleasures are
temporary but there's a lot of things I
love and I love the people in my life
I've been very fortunate I have my
wonderful wife Parris who unfortunately
couldn't be with me on this trip I have
an amazing staff of minions who serve me
one of them said is here with me tonight
and four or five others are at home they
they try to keep me working and try to
keep distractions at bay I look my
publishers David munch we didn't want me
to come here and and my editor and Grohl
and my wonderful publishers at Bantam
Doubleday Dell so there's a lot of
things that that make me happy
thank you
[Applause]